hey everybody uh beautiful day here in
L.A huh oh yeah I spent the whole day
today on
Facebook
um let me ask you guys this you guys
ever Google something you notice on your
Facebook wall there's an ad for the
thing you Googled well what the hell is
that I was on my Facebook wall day there
was an ad for sexy cougars
I was like Hey Google
that was between us
what the hell are you doing buddy I
thought I could tell you anything you're
blabbing the neighbors take it easy now
I'm all nervous around Google now it's
like that guy I can't trust anymore now
every time I Google something I'm very
ambiguous now I'm like uh spicy Latinas
for a friend
yeah the internet's a crazy thing I just
got an email from a hot gay guy this hot
gay guy email me gorgeous gay man
smoking hot what a bummer I'm not gay
this guy's a 10. yeah a hot gig I have
on a crush on you it's kind of like
finding a million pesos
now you're like oh man
I can't do much about this now but once
I cross that line I'll be set
oh yeah I like the gays any gay guys
here
well
that is statistically impossible
gay guys are the best another but perks
you know they're non-violent they fix up
neighborhoods and they're generally
smart people you never leave me an
ignorant gay guy now you never meet a
gay guy was like I only love three
things my truck my gun and dick
[Applause]
so much but what if you had a gay son
I wouldn't mind having a gay son having
a gay son's like finding a french fry in
your onion rings
you know you're like well it's not what
I expected bud
I like these too
yeah I am not gay do like the gals uh
went on a date with a girl once I went
pretty well went back to her place I
take out a condom she goes whoa whoa
whoa where'd you get that thing
I was like well they were free at the
bar
she was like Ah that's gross
I was like well that's where I got you
and you know these are all just jokes I
don't mean to offend the gals I try to
be a good feminist I do which is tough
nowadays because some women are
feminists and some women aren't so as a
guy how do I know how to act like some
girls you open the door for and they're
like wow a gentleman thank you very much
other girls you open the door for them
they're like well you think I can't open
my own door I'm like whoa hey I'm just
trying to sleep with you
this is Louise how do we get here
I do feel sorry for win when it comes to
sex though I think you guys get screwed
over you know guy has sex with a lot of
girls he's a cool guy a girl has sex
with a lot of guys everybody makes fun
of her that's not fair it's a double
standard I hate when guys pull this move
they go hey you know I had sex with that
girl I'm the man and you go yeah well
she had sex with him too and like oh
what a well that's not fair how
come she's a now come showing a
when she had sex with you you never
hear a guy say that she banged me
what a
wow you've got some problems sister get
your act together this this is a wake-up
call
I feel like we're so mean to promiscuous
girls in the society aren't we
she's loose she's easy well what
is that don't we all like sex while we
get mad at the one group giving it away
yeah we all like Banana Republic they
have a sale nobody calls them a
I don't get it we got a black president
now gay marriage is legal here yet
are still oppressed that's the one group
in this country that still gets stepped
on and I'm the only guys to get up for
these women even women won't stick up
for him those are ruin it for
everybody no you could put out too
I genuinely don't understand I feel like
if we're gonna make fun of a group of
girls let's make fun of the prude girls
right they're the boring annoying ones
let's kick them off the high horse
they've had it too good for too long
oh yeah why do we reward these women
no I don't put out till three months in
a relationship yeah you have nothing
else to offer get a personality got it
come on kick it up a notch let's go
because let's be honest you know prude
girls they're like Mom and Pop shops we
all pretend to like them but they're
more expensive and they close early
promiscuous girls are like Walmart all
right everybody makes fun of them
everybody talks down to them when you're
inside one at four in the morning you're
like man
I'm glad these are around
[Applause]
all right hey gonna be here in La a lot
of uh pretty gals here uh I find it hard
to approach women at a bar I feel like
women should hit on men more hit on us
ladies you can say whatever you want to
a guy I know a lady approached me once
she goes ooh I'm gonna kidnap you I was
like wow I can never say that to a woman
I said that to a lady she calls the
police I would be curious to know what a
woman could say that would offend me
like all right I'm gonna take you home
drug you take advantage you and film it
I'd be like all right well at least let
me pay for the Uber
I'm just jealous of you gals you have
options you have the freedom to say no
like if a girl goes on a date with a guy
and this guy takes out his Nazi
memorabilia she's like I get the hell
out of here if I go on date with a girl
she takes out her Nazi memorabilia I'm
like I gotta bang her and get the hell
out of here
will be a long winner
I don't know It's just tough to date now
you know we have no patience anymore we
want everything immediately now we want
everything quick we want Uber Tinder
Netflix everything's so quick now the
only thing we don't want quick is sex
when's that gonna catch up you know I
was with a girl night I finished kind of
early she's like hey what's going on
here I was like well these are the times
we're living in
come on I don't the patience for your
vagina to be buffering let's go
um gals are so sexy you're driving me
crazy this is how sexy girls are I was
out to dinner once this girl leans over
during the meal and goes hey I'm not
wearing any underwear I was like oh my
God that's hot then I realize why is
that sexy has underwear ever been a huge
obstacle for a guy has any guy ever
taken a girl's jeans off seeing panties
been like it's gonna be a long night
put a pot of coffee on I can't crack
that code but that's how hot you are
gals you can tell my article of clothing
you're not wearing I can't even see it
missing I'm already turned on doesn't
work for me as a guy I can't pull that
off I lean over during dinner hey I'm
not wearing underwear she's gonna go uh
oh what happened
I learned the hard way you can't say sex
on a date girls hate that it's like
saying bomb at the airport the whole
thing shuts down you know
where we all like sex it feels good but
you can't bring it up the only way to
get the thing you want is to pretend
like you don't want it that's weird
Behavior what if job interviews were
like that so Mark why do you want to
work here
who says I want to work here
I don't know maybe it's me maybe I'm
screwed up sexually you know I caught my
parents having sex when I was eight 21
and today
the idea of your parents having sex is
so horrifying isn't it that's why I'm
surprised parents don't use that as a
threat
wouldn't that be so effective like hey
Timmy better clean that room me and your
mom are going to go at it
I know that math test Billy I got a D
I'll show you some d
ude I don't know the gays have it
figured out yeah I love a good game my
roommate's gay I like having a gay
roommate he's gay I'm broke I feel like
poor people and gay people a lot in
common you know right we're both born
that way yeah yeah women just want to be
our friends and uh when you finally tell
your parents they're like yeah we knew
laughs I went to the Gay Pride Parade a
couple months ago still sore had a good
time yeah
uh they had the homophobic guys out
there with the big signs you know how
much you have to hate a group to make a
sign remember to sign in my whole life
these people are more prejudiced I am
productive yeah the markers the poster
board I don't get it you're tactic for
fighting gays is arts and crafts might
want to rethink that one
ironically the group you hate the most
really possess up that poster
I have the worst gaydar in the world too
I can't tell who's gay I didn't know my
roommate was gay until we had sex
too boy the Bible's a real Buzz Kill huh
they don't like anything fun the Bible
hates gays they hate trans that's gonna
be great we're doing stuff so sexually
Advanced not even in the Bible you know
like I love having sex with my robot the
guy's like
all right you're good
maybe I'll try it and uh sorry if I
offend anybody and now I'm trying to be
more PC I'm not good with the PC you
know I find it very phony you know you
know PC's phony because you never use it
in emergency
it's too many syllables the words would
take too long you know people are hurt
you got to help them you don't try to be
Progressive you got to be quick like if
you saw a Chinese guy get into a car
accident run over a black guy you can't
be like oh my God officer come quick
it's been a terrible tragedy an Asian
American man got into a car accident not
cause they're bad drivers
he ran over to African-American
gentlemen who's crossed the street
slowly not because they do that and uh
I come quick the guy's really hurt he's
drowning in a pool of his own blood not
because they can't swim
[Music]
I like to drink I've got a bit of a
problem uh I got really drunk last night
was incredibly hungover today had
another beer hangover went away
isn't that the amazing thing about booze
the thing that causes the problem is
also the solution yeah
I wish other problems were like that you
know like you have sex with a girl she
gets pregnant
have sex with her again no more baby
oh man that would be amazing you know
then you're guaranteed to get laid at
least twice
you know you're talking like last night
was incredible we should do that again
no I think I'm gonna go home hey
I'm just being responsible
I go a lot of bars my friend actually
works at a gay bar so I'll go there from
time to time get a free drink maybe a
compliment
my guy friends are blown away by this
they're like dude you go to gay bars
that is weird if some gay guy ever hit
on me I don't know what I would do
how about you just not have sex with
them
pretty easy
sometimes I wish I was gay seems pretty
good you know easy to hook up couple
mimosas fix up a neighborhood it's
fantastic you know
but you know do like the ladies big fan
of the gals uh which is weird because
when I was a kid I hated girls when I
was like six years old I thought girls
were gross thought they were dumb you
know you're allowed to hate girls as a
kid that's really the only group a kid's
allowed to hate
because if I was a six-year-old that
hated
Puerto Ricans
that would be weird
you know if I was like hey Mom I hate
Puerto Rican she would never say
oh you'll like them one day
all right any Puerto Ricans here
all right too many I uh
just kidding just kidding love Puerto
Ricans good people good people uh very
passionate people a lot of knives but
passion very passionate uh hey I'm just
telling jokes I'm a comedian like like I
live in New York City all right if I was
racist I would be exhausted
let's all take it easy huh
um but you guys are a great crowd some
people get so offended by these jokes
the gay joke the Puerto Rican joke I got
yelled at by a guy recently on the show
this guy comes up and goes hey buddy I'm
gay and Puerto Rican all right I don't
appreciate those jokes you know how hard
my life is I was like whoa take it easy
how hard your life is dude you have the
most parades
yes
all right
yeah yeah I don't know race is always
such a touchy issue we're all so
uncomfortable with our race these days
you know especially white people we're
all scared of looking racist that's a
big fear we have like I was talking to
one guy my last day job and I was like
hey man what's the name of that new guy
on the fifth floor the really tall black
guy and this guy goes whoa
[Laughter]
I don't see color
like really did you really just say that
that really just come out of your face
so I looked this guy right in the eye
and I was like hey man it's cool
I'm black
and he was like no you're not and I'm
like aha
ah yeah you may not be racist but you
are a liar
oh boy I'll tell you I was the uh I was
the victim of racism recently I should
tell you I love Jewish women that's my
number one love the Jewish any Jewish
gals here all right hey Shalom
um
love Jewish women I was actually lucky
enough to date a Jewish girl for a while
we talked about getting married and her
dad made us break up because I'm not
Jewish and I was like come on really
seriously like I live in New York I have
curly hair I'm circumcised I'm a
comedian I'm like right there
[Applause]
still still he was like no no my
daughter will only marry a Jew I want my
people to live on out my culture to live
on Jews are all about living on that's
when I thought man Jews must be really
jealous of gay people
because gay people can't even reproduce
yet they keep popping up
sitting around like he got to marry a
Jew you got to marry Jew and gays are
like we'll be fine
hey how you guys doing
all right hey good to be here uh it's
nice to be here again I like performing
here it's not too Swanky you know I hate
performing plays that are real Swanky I
did a show yesterday at a place with a
bathroom attendant
yeah I had a fun moment I walked in the
bathroom attended peeing
the tables have turned
so I go up behind him with a paper towel
I hand it to him I wait for a tip he
looks at me like I'm crazy and I went
exactly
flew here yesterday I hate flying that's
the only part of this job I hate tell
like a train give me an Amtrak any day
huh no bag check no security it's
amazing I hate flying flying is so high
maintenance flying's like a high
maintenance chick like you want to get
inside me got here an hour early take
your shoes off and do a body scan you're
like Jesus Christ oh Lord not a train a
train's like a drunk chick like get a
beer get in here
[Applause]
no security on a train whatsoever you
could walk on a train with three
suitcase full of cocaine like hey see
some say something
thank you
this is how sad and lonely trains are
trains don't ask to see your ticket
until the train has left the station
they've already started moving and then
they ask how much could they really care
tickets Please I don't have one we gotta
buy one now I don't have any money we'll
figure it out
yeah I was hungover on the flight I
drink too much and what you call a
functioning alcoholic any function
alcoholics there hey all right yeah yeah
yeah I
um I don't folks have a hug we got a bad
rap huh you know we're actually harder
working than everyone else we're doing
the same stuff you're doing drunk right
where's our parade what Bob showed up to
work on time screw Bob I slept here
I feel like uh you got a drink now that
the news is crazy so much stuff going on
a lot of racial stuff oh I uh I'm not
racist I look at racism the same way I
look at Nickelback
yeah it's fun to joke about but uh you
never want to see it live
I don't know I uh
I feel like you can't really be racist
these days you know you lose your job
you make headlines you get ostracized
from society it's very risky to be
racist nowadays that's why if anyone's
ever racist around you now you know they
trust you yeah
it's weird Bittersweet moment you know
you're on a smoke break with some guys
like man I can't stand Mexicans you're
like holy hell you're full of hate but I
didn't know we were so close
um I grew up in the South too I've seen
some crazy stuff I grew up with this guy
hates minorities hates them all Jewish
black Mexican Asian whatever but he just
had a baby which I find strange because
babies and minorities have all the same
negative stereotypes if you hate
minorities you date babies too I mean
think about it babies are loud in movie
theaters they can't swim they all look
alike
they're lazy they don't work they can't
drive they never tip yeah they come to
this country not knowing the language
you can almost hear the blogs heating up
yeah
I a single guy back on the scene uh hey
all right prove it
always bring your own condom that's what
I say Sir yeah I uh I was fooling around
the girl recently she goes hey do you
have a condom I said I forgot she goes I
might have one she starts digging
through her stuff she finds One Magnum
foreign
damn it this went from a good time to a
challenge
all right well let's give it a whirl why
not so she ripped it open she rolled it
on and it fit it fit and I gotta tell
you people that is a man's version of
Cinderella right there
[Applause]
yeah single my last girlfriend dumped me
said I wasn't manly enough for her and
I'm a manly guy that one hurt yeah I
didn't know we were allowed to say stuff
like that like I'm all about equality
but how about a woman can say something
like yeah that guy was good with his
hands he could fix stuff around the
house and you're like all right cool but
if a guy says hey like a woman can cook
people go whoa whoa It's not the 50s
well how come her job or me is okay my
driver's not okay also who doesn't like
somebody can fix stuff around the house
I'd love to come home my girlfriend's
like hey Bill's the deck
amazing
I'll do laundry
see I think women are really smart
because you guys made your gender roles
offensive
yeah that was very clever
well played ladies well played guys how
great would that be if we get offended
now your girlfriend wakes up at 4am I
heard glass shattering somebody break in
you're like well it's not the 50s go
check it out
all right
good to be here a little hungover uh
runs in the family my dad's a drinker
although my uncle he got his act
together my uncle is 30 years sober can
believe that 30 years sober
yeah yeah the other night I was like oh
man I got so drunk I lost my phone my
uncle's like oh yeah I did that once I
was like wow you know how drunk you have
to be to lose your phone 30 years ago
holy hell
are you telling me you got hammered and
lost a landline
those were attached to the wall
yeah I don't know drink at least the fun
stuff you know I met the girlfriend one
night stand it's a good time uh during
the sex you kept yelling out baby baby
baby oh baby kept saying baby over and
over again so I yelled out relationship
she was like what the hell are you doing
I was like Oh I thought we're just
yelling out stuff we don't want
I don't know weird how we say baby in
bed why are we yelling out the thing we
don't want to happen you know you don't
do that with food chili dog diarrhea
weird baby how did baby get in there
it's like a sexy word baby right because
you can't be like ah a toddler
yeah
I don't know words are weird uh but it's
got to be tough to be a lady you know a
friend of mine she's got cheated on by a
guy she's really mad she's like ah men
are dogs they're all dogs that's a weird
Choice when a guy cheats huh because
aren't dogs literally the most loyal
animal right
you can do anything a dog stick with you
hit a woman kill a kid dog's like he's
home
all right
you know if anything guys you cheat are
more like cats you know they're all
nervous freaking out head on a swivel
all right always on edge where were you
last night
yeah I don't know
sometimes wish I was gay that seems
pretty good I used to live with a gay
guy he seemed to have it all figured out
you know gay guys can get away with more
I actually got let go from a job once
for sexual harassment I told a woman she
had nice legs they fired me which really
bothered me because my gay friends at
work got away with murder they'd be like
hey Shelly how are you honk honk
it's like what why is that okay like
well they're not attracted to women I
was like so what I'm not attracted to
kids I can't go to a playground hey
Timmy yeah
foreign
right like you're a woman wouldn't you
rather be complimented by a group that's
into you I don't care if a lesbian
compliments me nothing against lesbian
but that didn't help my ego yeah but
lesbian's like hey Mark like a haircut
I'm like I know you have the same one
tell me at all
I don't know is that offensive I can't
tell what's offensive anymore we've
we've ruined that word you know I don't
know I was at a Starbucks recently this
guy gave him my coffee I went hey thanks
Chief this guy goes ooh
don't say Chief that's offensive to
Native Americans
I was like how is that offensive he goes
whoa don't say how yeah
well I don't know I uh I don't know I
have no hatred towards any group I just
you know I just like the words who's got
the energy be racist who's got the time
put on an outfit go to a meeting oh yeah
I don't know I don't care I don't care
about any group enough to hate it go
nuts do whatever you want I have no
opinions hey you hear these guys like ah
what about these Muslims on airplanes
I'm like well I'd rather a Muslim on a
plane than a baby
yeah that 100 better experiences with
Muslims than children I'm just saying if
the airport had a baby ban I wouldn't
protest
everybody's up in arms about something
these days transgender that's the big
one now ah transgender they're using the
bathrooms well they're still using
toilets right they're not leaving a hot
floater in the sink
yeah that was the case yeah we should
have a talk I'm trying to wash my hands
here but uh clean the toilet then you
get the hillbilly guy well what if one
of these perverts puts on a dress and
looks at my wife in the bathroom oh what
a score some guy could see your fat wife
taking a dump yeah what a lucky guy
come on go to work you lunatic well
we've come a long way in this country
you know come a long way like uh you
know in the 50s we had whites only and
blacks only water fountains which is
incredibly sad especially if you're a
thirsty Asian
yeah what the hell are they doing no one
ever talks about when they drink out of
a hose never heard a thing about it yeah
black people are angry can you believe
this we got an old Water Foundation like
can I get a sip I'm dying out here
to fight then we'll take the convenience
stores
I don't know a lot of racial talk these
days White Privilege doesn't turn me
here a lot now White Privilege I was at
a grocery store recently with a friend
of mine he's black I stole a candy bar I
love to steal I get a little rush
I get outside I'm all proud of myself my
friend goes white privilege White
Privilege I was like wow no this was a
robbery
if I had gotten caught and gotten away
with it that would be my privilege this
is me being an amazing thief and he was
like no no it's white privileges the guy
didn't fly around the store he followed
me around the store and I was like well
yeah that's why I brought you
yeah hey good to be here I I ubered here
that was I had a real chatty driver huh
don't you hate that would it be nice if
there was a small talk option on the app
you know but there isn't so you gotta
really find your own way to quiet the
guy I like to scare him you know he's
like hey how about this traffic what do
you think's causing this I'm like
probably the Jews he's like
all right
nice quiet ride yeah I'm staying in a
West Hollywood very gay area which I
like big fan of the gays oh hey all
right
thanks for coming out
um yeah
big fan uh I feel like gay guy is just a
little better than us the only
Progressive non-violent you never meet
any violent gay guys there's no gay
gangs that would just be a musical yeah
I have uh the worst gaydar on the planet
I can't tell who's gay my friends always
brag about his gaydar we'll go out he's
like he's gay he's gay he's gay I'm like
well that's not that impressive I mean
we're at a gay bar
I don't know you want an impress you
with your gaydar start pointing out gay
babies
that's impressive like see that kid
breastfeeding over there between you and
me he's miserable
I'm not gay seeing a lady my girlfriend
she's obsessed with murder shows like
Dateline Forensic Files and she caught
me watching like two seconds of gay porn
she flipped out
she was like what the hell is this I was
like well you watch murder
isn't that way worse
he's just two people having sex your
things the first commandment this isn't
even on the list
she was like well do you want to do this
I was like well do you want to kill me
foreign
she was like oh shut up I'm just
watching this so I know what to do if
ever get in that situation I'm like well
maybe that's why I'm watching gay porn
yeah she's like oh that's ridiculous
this is a reenactment well so is this
this guy's not really a real estate
broker
hey you guys are a fun crowd you know a
lot of crowds now very sensitive
everybody's so offended these days words
I always get jealous when people get
offended they go hey that joke offended
me I'm like wow I wish I cared about
anything as much you cared about that
joke
what's it like to feel
the only feeling I really get is
loneliness I feel very lonely as a guy
who doesn't get offended a fan of people
like get together they make signs they
protest I don't know if we don't get
together never see a bunch of unoffended
people outside of a university like
[Music]
yeah but I don't look where it's gotten
us the whole country feels angry we're
all pent up we got white supremacists
protests all the time hate groups now
you're allowed to be hateful in America
as long as you're not specific you know
if you go I hate Jewish people everybody
goes oh my God what a bigot Prejudice
but if you go I hate people everybody
goes tell me about it
foreign
oh yeah people are angry man I had one
of those uh White lives matter rallies
go by my house the other day I freaked
out then I realized ah it's just a half
marathon
[Applause]
women are going through a lot right now
women are having a real moment you know
men are nervous these days men are
scared looking like creeps have you
noticed now when a woman posts a picture
on Facebook it's mostly women commenting
like you're beautiful you're gorgeous
you're sexy Agave like cool hat
but hey you gotta listen to ladies
fellas you got to listen like a friend
of mine she's like a big feminist she's
like ah I have a full Bush because
that's how I was born I was like holy
hell you were born with a full bush
that is a terrifying baby
cut the umbilical cord I can't find it
also that baby's gay
yeah some guys just like whipping it out
that's wild yeah I think guys get
confused because ladies sometimes you
like a penis so I think guys like hey
she liked one last night why wouldn't
she like one by the copy machine women
are so complex
because I think generally speaking men
are a little more constant you know like
men like boobs but we like boobs across
the board you know you know boob in the
bedroom great
boob on the bus
also great
penis in the bedroom great penis on the
bus
call the police
nobody's calling the police on a boob if
you see a boob out in the wild it's like
seeing a deer you're like
it's Majestic and your friend walks up
hey look at that a boob you're like ah
you spooked it
thanks a lot I'm Kevin Hart